hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes art and makes
it competitive and today it's the
program that will take bffs and turn
them into mcrs
which stands for marvel cinematic rivals
i'll come up with something better at
some point it's benedict cumberbatch
taking on his good pal tom hiddleston
and the great british bromance bonanza
that's good that that's why i get to
host silence your ego two of the finest
actors working today will be going at it
for five growing rounds i'm mark ellison
my job is to decide who's better at what
and which is on first in one corner it's
benedict cumberbatch who's done
everything from shakespeare to marvel to
sherlock and a couple historical epics
sprinkled in and in the other corner
it's tom hiddleston your savior
who's done everything from big time
blockbusters to gothic romances to tiny
little indies all too much critical
acclaim now we may know them best as dr
strange and loki from those talking
picture book movies but today it's a
thorough examination of their entire
careers inside and out and i left my
surgical gloves in the car again here's
how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score
round 3 iconic rolls round 4 memorable
moments and then we'll do a wild card
round that could involve who does the
better cosplay of themselves at
comic-con or who's on the fast track to
win an oscar or who does the better show
on the small screen we got sherlock in
the night manager it might as well make
them fight it out right try me beyonce
look given their shared movie history i
don't know who's faster but they're both
going to lose the war horse which is
conveniently the film that they both
worked on together as their careers were
shifting into high gear a bromance was
born and we're all just lucky to witness
it i've never met this man in my life
but the highlander rules are in effect
here meaning there can be only one the
winner gets to stay in the mcu and the
loser has to remake the phantom
yeah slam evil shall we begin
let's get it on round one box office
if we're looking at which actor can
boast more movie theater coin we might
have picked two of the best because
their theater receipts are longer than
the ones they dole out at cbs and that's
thanks in large part to the mcu but not
limited to just that galaxy i am
burdened with glorious purpose since i'm
a nice fellow i'm gonna go ahead and
give them each 156 million dollars to
start which is how much war horse made
back in 2011. from there on you fellas
are on your own
unless you know you're in the same mcu
movie which was the case for avengers
infinity war end game and kinda thor
ragnarok endgame still has a claim as
the most successful big screen flick
ever with its almost 2.8 billion dollar
draw backing it up infinity war also
cracked two billion dollars and thor
ragnarok did 850 million which was more
thanks to tom than benny doctor actually
do i really have to say benedict
cumberbatch the entire show call me
stephen hiddleston or hids made his mcu
debut with the og thor movie and is
starred in every one of those films
since the asgardian brothers kicked off
with a 449 million dollar take then the
sequel the dark world drew in 644
million dollars worth of earthling bucks
and they made you proud but in between
is when we really learned how to love or
hate or swoon over loki that's when he
was the primary antagonist in the
avengers a movie that would go on to
crack the 1.5 billion dollar mark
so tom got into the mcu first how's that
going to help him out against b-slice my
name is dr steven strange well as dr
strange cumberbatch's standalone flick
pulled in 676 million dollars but it was
far from the actor's first huge movie he
played various roles in the hobbit
prequels he was the grinch to the tune
of 513 million dollars and he played
definitely we swear it's not khan in
star trek into darkness spurring it on
to a 467 million dollar hall i am
better at what everything tom hiddleston
isn't just resting on his mcu orals
either as one of the lead humans in kong
skull island he ushered in 561 million
dollars and the rom-com hit midnight in
paris in which tom played f scott
fitzgerald old sported its way to 162
million dollars worldwide however
hiddleston also has tiny movies like i
saw the light only lovers left alive and
the deep blue sea
which i'll point out right now is not
the shark movie with ll cool j i know
you wanted to see loki swim with
genetically enhanced makos so did i not
my forte
anyway none of those three movies even
did four million dollars on the big
screen while cumberbatch had similar
returns with films like the
whistleblower and the mauritanian he's
also got way more blockbuster firepower
literally as is the case with world war
one's epic 1917 that earned 370 million
dollars across the globe and world war
ii's the imitation game which jack aid
two two seven million at the multiplex
what do you say
i don't know he's probably getting paid
by the word i might need a turing
machine to calculate all those
incredible returns from tom and ben but
we're gonna go out on a limb and guess
that their median movie hauls in an
asgardian load of bread as well tom
hiddleston actually has the higher
perflic average at
587 million dollars every time he suits
up cover batches is a measly 453 million
dollars so you'd think this would be an
easy win for the night manager guy right
i can't see it in the future i'm not a
witch no
why'd you dress like one no not so fast
benny's total dollars generated is 14
billion dollars against tommy's 9.39
billion and while the vast majority of
hiddleston's huge hits are from the mcu
cumberbatch has more evenly spread the
wealth to other franchises and
standalone successes which means
i'm giving the win to benedict it's a
close call both competitors have
arguments i can't say no to 14 billion
dollars is fun for you round two tomato
meter slash audience score
so usually when you see eye-popping box
office numbers like a combined 24
billion dollars you might think to
yourself yeah but i bet those movies got
ripped apart by the critics
well to that i say stop being so
negative if the mcu has taught us
anything it's that you can find armored
suit if you're rich enough and critics
and audiences can both gush over your
films at the same time oh my
both of these dudes can brag about
freshness for days you're welcome ladies
and that includes their comic book movie
outings the avengers is fresh at 91
percent and that ain't even the top of
the heap thor ragnarok is 93 percent and
end game is 94 percent hiddleston has
occupied
i don't know if i'm pronouncing it right
no i don't suppose you do but it's 96
and the perfectly accented midnight in
paris at 91
cummerbash has the power of the dog
tying endgame at 94 percent and 12 years
of slave is at 95 percent so yeah these
dudes are fresh do you think flattery
will keep you alive
doctor strange is at 89
as is the imitation game and atonement
is 83 i loved that movie when i saw it
no idea if i'll still like it haven't
seen it in a minute i'm also going to
give a major shout out to the
whistleblower at 75 which ties it with
you guessed it the between two ferns
movie that cumberbatch did have a role
in you got your start doing theater in
independent films i did and now you're
acting in marvel movies how good does it
feel to sell out oh and the penguins of
madagascar is at 74
basically anything starring benedict
cumberbatch is fresh right oh clearly
oh well the fifth estate is just 35
the other berlin girl is 43
and remember that one jungle book movie
he's sheri con in the other one and
that's at 53
still rotten well thank you for putting
it so delicately okay so i'd say the
door is a jar but barely if hiddleston
wants to stroll through for a round two
win what's that the dude only has one
rotten movie what's to expect like ever
if it's king kong i'm walking right out
of this shoot okay good we're safe skull
island and resort is 75
crimson peak is 72 percent and even thor
the dark world is safe at 66 percent
okay and now for tom hiddleston's one
rotten movie drum roll please or in this
case maybe a jaunty country guitar it's
the hank williams biopic i saw the light
i thought he was good as old hank but
that's actually the lowest tomato meter
depth that either actor reaches why'd
you gotta say that but when we look at
averages it's tom on top with the 78 per
film average on the tomato meter to
benedict's 74 percent and even though
they flip beds on the audience score
side of things with cumberbatch besting
his bud by an average of 72 percent to
65
that only one rotten movie ever stat is
special let's keep an eye on that and
maybe don't make any hank williams jr
movies anytime soon oh i surely know
that for funsies benedict cumberbatch
and tom hiddleston have both starred in
successful tv series as well tom has the
night manager at 91
henry v the hollow crown at 98
and loki is super fresh at 92 percent
mostly thanks to the alligator
benedict was also in that henry v thing
as well as sherlock at 78
and melrose place at 90 percent look if
you're not going to start making sense
i'm just gonna have to put this thing
back on whoops no that's patrick mowers
at 90
tom hiddleston is happy because he gets
the very slight knot in round two and
that ties our game one to one surprise
round three iconic rolls and now we get
to properly gush about how great these
guys are as loki and doc weird
respectively it's strange
maybe it's not just that they're good at
wearing capes or being sneaky no i wear
a cloak
these are a-list talents and they give
everything they have to these
performances and that bleeds over into
comic-con where they've both been seen
on stage in full costume much to the
delighted squeals of fans like me i am
burdened with glorious purpose stephen
strange goes through such a tumultuous
first hour in his debut movie it's a
good thing that benedict cumberbatch is
at the wheel he can pull off super evil
you care
so much don't you evil or just elitist
douche with equal ease or answer me this
bachelor's degree
for strange it was the latter but only
for a few fleeting scenes before a
tragic accident tosses him into a new
world bigger than anything this man of
science could have comprehended the
realization of his new gifts and how to
not abuse them is the journey the
character takes us the audience on and
benedict is a sight to behold but does
anyone have more fun in the mcu than
loki
madam a god doesn't plead i mean come on
that's the shakespearean role of a
lifetime because you get to either be
the bad guy is this not your natural
state the anti-hero i'm gonna burn this
place to the ground i'll show you where
my desk is you can start there the
temperamental brother or the trickster
or maybe all of those characters rolled
into one which path those are being
tapped into at any moment is a mystery
that audiences take delight in unpacking
as thomas sharp and crimson peak we meet
a very different mentality one is locked
into a house even as they might want to
leave hiddleston pulls this role off
with such a beautiful combination of
inferring that this house is his
everything it's a privilege we were born
into
one we can never relinquish at the same
time his eyes hint that he needs to get
the hell out at some point he can also
beat the crap out of scary prehistoric
bugs snakes primates his soldier turned
fortune hunter has a reassuring
leadership presence that comes from his
physicality as i'm shoving popcorn into
my face in an air-conditioned theater i
believe that this guy could help bail me
out of a jam on some uncharted island
like the skull one let me list all the
ways you're gonna die
meanwhile cumberbatch certainly has
roles where i don't want him to bail me
out or even be in the same state as me
he can be that menacing as a plantation
owner who knows what the right thing to
do is he shows us cowardice at the
crucial moment that met so many slaves
longing to be freed i have a debt to be
mindful of 12 years of slave is
heartbreaking for so many reasons one of
which is benedict's refusal to be an
ally then we get to the power of the dog
which earned him his second academy
award nomination he can be cruel and
sympathetic-ish as phil burbank a cowboy
who shows glimpses of humanity even as
his life path feels like it's already
been spelled out heck when benedict
cumberbatch isn't even on screen he can
still be a film's most lurking presence
its roles in the grinch and smaug that
might get him the edge here for the
grinch him and the dog max have such
wonderful chemistry that i was rooting
for them even before i was supposed to
they also pretty much live out my ideal
existence so that helped
[Music]
just me the dog a place to relax i don't
need money because if you got too much
coin laying around chances are there
could be a giant dragon snoozing inside
of it did you think i did not know this
day would come the hobbit films i'm a
little mixed on but seeing smaug emerge
from his golden slumber is epic and it's
a great reminder for all you kids to
never wake up uncle mark when he's
napping i instilled terror in the hearts
of men both gents have a ton of range so
much so that it might factor in a little
later in this very show but for now real
life the fictional fantastical and
authentic roles inhabited by benedict
cumberbatch slightly outweigh those of
tom hiddleston although i do really want
to see a battle between sherlock and
loki
i think loki would take that but benny
wins this round and he goes up on his
buddy two to one who actually believes
this buncombe round four memorable
moments
and now we've arrived at the round that
most of you tuned in for it wasn't to
see me your incredibly handsome host why
would you think that or to see the
almost as attractive tom hiddleston or
benedict cumberbatch here in studio rude
because that was never gonna happen
right we didn't try did we make a call
we made a call i mean you didn't think
i'd really come and see you did it this
place is disgusting but now we get to
the phase where we relive all those
amazing scenes and sequences and
settings that made these stars and their
films into hollywood legends it's an
ongoing process but come on hulk tossing
loki around like a ragdoll
[Music]
dr strange begging the ancient one teach
me they're great gifts but hey kids did
you know that the parent of a gif is the
movie itself that is hilarious so before
we get to those moment churning mcu
roles let's open with an appetizer like
con okay we knew it was going to be khan
the whole time but still getting to the
end of star trek into darkness to
witness that reveal was pretty damn cool
and we got to see an awesome spock
versus john harris i'm kidding i'm
really con battle i wouldn't want to
tussle with them but when a talking
dragon's voice is even more imposing
than the look you might want to pull a
monty python in
smell literally says i am fire i am
death which is going to be a swipe left
for me hiddleston has plenty of solid
moments in his other big flicks as well
i love when we meet his james conrad in
kong skull island it's a dingy wellwood
bar we have no idea who this dude is or
what he wants but we do know that he
better be on our side and he lives up to
that promise once we're in the wildest
jungle kinda sorta known to man and even
though he's great in the movie my
favorite moment is still
kong in the water he's just chilling
getting a bath doing some frontier
medicine i really think we'd be friends
but with thomas cher from crimson peak
we got to be friends because uh i'm not
coming over to your place you can crash
on my couch of course forgive me that
house is so creepy and hiddleston plays
along with a tom fullery every step of
the way he has such amazing chemistry
with his co-stars in that film and tilda
swinton and only lovers left alive not
enough folks caught that jim jarmusch
film but them on screen together is
magic oh and did i mention he plays a
vampire musician in it so you know get
on watching that
before we get to those tilda swinton
benedict cumberbatch moments let's
remember how great he was as alan turing
a role that earned ben his first oscar
nomination when he cracks the enigma
code it's stand up and cheer worthy but
it's also the scenes that sadden us that
are noteworthy in a less tolerant time
turing was hiding his sexuality as best
he could but when it's discovered it's a
heart-wrenching moment to witness
if we do veer into the fertile ground of
the mcu doctor strange is a good entry
point even though marvel had been
cranking up beloved hits for years by
the time this one came around the good
doctor reminded us that there's always
something new and breathtaking to
discover his first stroll as the guy we
know from the comic books is perfectly
handled as is the jarring car crash that
changes the course of this a-hole's life
forever you think you see through me do
you well you don't what he was a great a
a-hole just ask rachel mcadams his
character they have a chat at his place
that shows what they could have had and
why he ruined it all men am i right
and this is the part where you apologize
cumberbatch is also always welcome as a
bartender in a post-credits scene and i
do get a kick out of how doctor strange
interacts with other fellow avengers his
first meet up with tony stark and
infinity war is a blast and he has a
nice big broke kinship with peter parker
and spider-man no way home
that is until the kid trapped steven
some multiverse waiting room damn
teenagers ow pete broke some good guy
rules but his heart was in the right
place however as loki always reminds us
sometimes it's just more fun to be bad
we feel his tortured soul as the other
brother from the first thor film on but
it's cleverly hidden by a devilish sense
of humor and a willingness to follow
through on threats the climax of the
avengers is a feast that is largely on
the dime of loki and i do love how we
revisit that sequence from a different
perspective in avengers end game loki
can talk his way into and out of any
situation
just about any situation thanks for the
reminder thanos he's such a cool
conniving villain that when black widow
tricked him with his own overconfidence
we as the audience realize that natasha
is much more than just a cool martial
arts master benedict cumberbatch eeked
out a win in the best roles round but
here it's the parts played by tom
hiddleston that gave us the more
memorable moments if it did come to a
tie i'd take tom's hank williams
crooning over benedict's little charles
in august of sage county
[Music]
no offense but uh you ain't no hank
williams and with that we're suddenly
tied at two to two as we head into
oh right i'm supposed to ask what time
is it
it's time for the wild card round now
you see me
and if you've ever been to a magic show
kid's birthday party or saw one of those
jesse eisenberg movies you know that the
next logical line is now you don't well
for cucumber and hiddlebum that feels
weird but i'll allow it i think that's
what they call each other we see them as
many characters on screen but the lion's
share of recognition is from their mcu
roles dr strange and loki okay so that's
where we see them but this round we'll
be asking where we don't which actor has
a performance on their resume that is
most unlike their iconic comic book role
they're both going to give a great
effort here because of their incredible
training as thespians that goes all the
way back to their days as youts benedict
cumberbatch's first work as a
professional actor was in the world of
shakespeare leading up to that was a
master's degree in classical acting from
the london academy of music and dramatic
art
meanwhile i majored in communications i
i had hoped for a bit more tom
hiddleston also gained prominence and
award nominations for his stage work can
we not discuss my personal life in
public and in 2008 he was featured in a
west end revival of ivanov acting
alongside some bloke named kenneth
branagh brown and i were going to direct
thor and after working with tom he cast
him as loki so hids and batches come
from pedigrees way too admirable for me
to be giving them those nicknames as
we're disappearing into a role for
cumberbatch i'm going to go with phil
burbank from the power of the dog and
with hiddleston i'm gonna roll with
freddie page in the deep blue sea and
again there's way less sharks in it you
know don't even watch this movie for the
sharks paige is charming like loki is
but whereas loki is constantly thinking
a few steps ahead freddy is more overtly
tortured by his wartime hauntings his
hope is to sing away the post-traumatic
blues he feels for the loss of his
friends and the atrocities he had to
witness and commit for his country
hiddleston is unreal on this part and
he's so good at giving us a simmering
temper that's just below the surface but
like those sharks and another blue sea
occasionally it breaches the surface why
do you come around again soon when i've
got some self-respect back as phil
burbank cumberbatch took a very method
approach to playing this layered guy who
can definitely be mean spirited seldom
tender and always secretly yearning to
be accepted for who he really is he's a
closeted cowboy who can still seem so
confident and self-assured in those few
moments when we see real humanity it's a
guy who loves nature feels its rhythms
and can enjoy the stillness it provides
even as an emotional tornado is
constantly brewing deep inside it's such
a tough call between these two
performances both might give tiny
glimpses into their mcu characters but
they firmly inhabit these roles with
such devotion and conviction that we
cease to acknowledge them as benedict
and tom that's phil and that's freddy
until the credits are done rolling so
before they play me off the stage i'm
gonna go with
benedict cumberbatch and the deciding
metric might be that he's gone home with
a handful more of awards than his good
buddy tom but we could revisit this
matchup in a few years and
maybe they'll show up then guys we offer
parking heaven's now
but to stump for tom hiddleston i will
say that his emerging from the darkness
as loki in comic-con's famed hallway
years ago still stands as the you had to
be their moment from that wonderful
event in san diego i was lucky enough to
be on hand and the way that he
completely commanded that room full of
over 6 000 fans was truly a sight to
behold doctor strange a couple years
later that was really cool too
well that does it for us here today at
versus the decision has been rendered
but remember it's just my take i'm not a
jury i'm not an executioner i don't even
have my own daytime judge show
yeah so hit me up on social media at
mark ellis live with your opinion and be
sure to follow us here at rotten
tomatoes for all the latest in the world
of movies tv and whatever hidey and
cumberbund are up to they're good lads
and great sports thanks for watching
especially you tom and new benedict i'm
mark ellis and it's time to hop into my
ford fusion for the glorious purpose
of going home and walking the dog
you